beaucoup de travailleurs font depuis
deux mois du télétravail une pratique de
plus en plus courante qui ne l'étaient
pas nécessairement avant la crise
jean-nicolas wright et professeur
adjoint à la faculté de gestion
desautels de l'université de mcgill
monsieur wade bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
fait votre thèse de doctorat sur le
télétravail est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on
n'a jamais autant parlé de télétravail
en effet on n'a jamais autant parlé de
télétravail le télétravail était un gros
sujet de recherche et de discussions
vers la fin des années 90 jusqu'à 2005
et puis ensuite on est passé plus vers
le travail mobile mais maintenant on est
vraiment en train de revenir sur du
télétravail à la maison tels que tel que
ça a été pensée originale et est ce que
vous diriez même d'emblée que la crise
actuelle main change totalement la donne
sur nos télés travail sur notre
perception du télétravail oui parce que
le télétravail n'est jamais été
implémenté complètement dans les
entreprises c'est vraiment limitée à
moins de 10% des employés pour un ou
deux jours par mois donc c'est pas
c'était vraiment vu comme un cadeau
qu'on fait à adé des plus tôt des
employés de haut niveau qui sont très
indépendants rend très autonome et ça
n'a jamais vraiment été vu comme quelque
chose en termes de continuité ou de
productivité
c est là c'est vraiment là que c'est
complètement différent et vous vous
intéressez particulièrement à ce que
disent les dirigeants des entreprises à
leurs actionnaires il ya des conférences
des conférences téléphoniques notamment
vous avez constaté puis on va le voir
dans un graphique que vous avez préparé
une mention des mentions de plus en plus
fréquents du télétravail depuis le début
de l'année quand on regarde les semaines
la sas et les 19 semaines depuis le
début de l'année depuis le début du mois
de janvier
on a vu clairement à partir du mois de
mars qu on mentionnait de plus en plus
la question du télétravail dans les
réunions avec les actionnaires
tout à fait mais déjà si vous regardez
de la semaine 1 à aldi silva déjà
beaucoup plus de mention que
traditionnellement puisque avant 2020
j'ai pu compter que 300 mention de pdg
du télétravail c'était vraiment pas un
sujet du tout et ça c'est sur 120 milles
transcrivent donc c'est vraiment sujet
grâce à la réalisation à remettre la
graphique merci beaucoup voyez-vous ils
ont lu dans mon esprit continuez
monsieur wright et est donc
effectivement vous voyez vraiment qu'on
est passé de 0 % en 2019 de 2006 à 2010
9 à tout d'un coup on est au-delà de 40%
sur plusieurs semaines consécutives
c'est vraiment devenu un sujet de
conversation des pdg avec l'investisseur
intéressant intéressant de voir cet
intérêt grandissant quand on dit ça on
dit souvent que c'est une solution
écologique
est-ce que c'est selon vous une vraie
bonne solution écologique
oui le télétravail a été théorisé dans
les années 90 comme une réponse à à la
pollution comme une réponse aussi à la
pollution mentale du bruit des grandes
villes du stress et effectivement ça
s'est jamais vraiment passé comme ça
mais mais je pense qu'on est en train
déjà de voir en terme de pollution une
amélioration une amélioration
significative web est là parce que la
plupart des entreprises ont fermé ont
mis fin à leurs activités temporairement
mais il est certain que plus de gens à
la maison en télétravail c'est moins de
congestion routière et moins de
véhicules sur les routes
effectivement et là on est vraiment dans
une situation extrême dans le sens où on
est vraiment dans une pandémie mais si
vous imaginez par exemple de laisser des
gens de télé travailler une journée par
semaine deux journées par semaine ça
fait déjà à notre infrastructure ça fait
déjà un soulagement considérable c'est
vrai en même temps est-ce que ce serait
pas quand même très dommageable pour la
vitalité économique des centre-villes la
vitalité commerciale les commerces aussi
qui dépendent des travailleurs qui sont
dans les bureaux puis ça créerait aussi
beaucoup de locaux vacants en
perspective non je pense effectivement
que on est dans une phase vraiment de
transition et donc de toute façon je
veux dire sur l'année 2020 on aura une
forme de distance mans sociale et donc
la majorité où une grande partie des
personnes vont télétravail et donc on
est déjà dans cette situation là
maintenant ouais mais c'est autrement
dit c'est pas sans conséquence il ya des
conséquences positives mais il ya aussi
des conséquences économiques négatives
durant
la transition où on passerait un mode où
le télétravail serait beaucoup plus
fréquent est beaucoup plus utilisé
tout à fait est-ce qu'on télétravail est
aussi une façon de réduire les coûts
d'exploitation pour une entreprise c'est
vraiment intéressant puisque j'ai fait
une analyse thématique de ce que les pdg
discute donc pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
parlent du télétravail pourquoi est ce
que toutes ces semaines ils sont pas et
effectivement depuis deux trois semaines
ce que je vois c'est qu'il ya
l'émergence d'un thème qui est le long
terme et l'immobilier et donc les pdg
sont en train de réfléchir à comment
survivre cette crise et donc ils
s'intéressent vraiment au télétravail
mais ils se rendent compte aussi
maintenant que l'entreprise tourne en
télétravail
les gens sont productifs et d'eau qu'ils
réfléchissent à réduire leurs coûts de
l'immobilier pour pouvoir rebondir plus
vite les vous êtes les gens sont
productifs comment s'assure de leur
productivité
je pense que il faut il faut pas
réfléchir à transposer les modes de
gestion face à face au mode de gestion
avec les télétravailleurs
je pense que beaucoup un mécanisme
vraiment très fréquent d'entreprise en
face à face et de de contrôler comment
les gens font leur travail mais je pense
qu en télétravail c'est pas possible de
faire ça c'est déjà été identifiés dans
la recherche à de nombreuses reprises il
faut réfléchir a expliqué à chaque
télétravailleurs pourquoi il fait ce
travail et en quoi ça s'inscrit dans la
stratégie globale de l'entreprise parce
que c'est vraiment ça à mon sens le
risque c'est d'avoir des gens qui sont
séparés chez eux
isolé et en fait on est juste en train
de réfléchir à ce qu'ils soient
productifs mais on réfléchit pas comment
ils s'inscrivent dans cette entreprise
c'est vraiment par exemple ça concerne
des millions de lé millions canadiens
on a un autre tableau a présenté où on
voit que le télé de travail à faire
exploser les plateformes de vidéo
conférence en prenons aux hommes par
exemple 10 millions de participants en
2010 9 en décembre 2010 9 300 millions
en avril 2020 effectivement je pense que
c'est ça montre aussi ce qui a été
démontré dans la recherche souvent c'est
que quand on doit avoir une
communication sur des sujets complexes
avec
les gens par exemple un projet de
travail c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
efficace de collaborer sur des médias
riches comme la vidéo on peut voir le
regard des gens on peut voir leur
expression on ne fait pas que entendre
leur joie ou que lire leurs emails donc
c'est vraiment ça ne m'étonne pas que
les gens se soit porté naturellement
vers des plateformes comme zoom qui
permettent de recréer ce face à face
même si on est très séparés par la
distance
voilà je remarque les les maisons des
gens depuis qu'on fait jusqu'à et puis
de la vidéoconférence comme ça donc vous
êtes le premier à présenter vos poissons
en direct sur est merci à l'air apaisant
et agréable à la prochaine merci merci